And I have to tell you,
I have read everything
you've ever written.
No, I mean it.
I mean, when I read Euphoria at Midnight,
all I wanted to do was become a writer.
Oh, please, honey.
Listen,
if I can do it, anybody
can you just start with
half a dozen European cities,
throw in 30 euphemisms
for male genitalia, and bam,
You have got yourself a book.
My mother.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I was actor Matthew Perry
and his iconic role
as Chandler Bing on Friends.
The beloved actor was found dead
in a hot tub at his home
in Los Angeles on Saturday.
A law enforcement source tells CNN
there is no foul play suspected.
Perry's death is under investigation.
Perry landed several high
profile TV
roles and movies in movies
and TV shows like Beverly Hills,
92 on Oth throughout his career.
But it was his unforgettable
role as Chandler Bing
that made him a household name.
The creators of Friends
released a statement saying, quote,
He was always
the funniest person in the room.
More than that,
he was the sweetest
with a giving and selfless heart.
Joining us now from Kansas
City, Missouri,
where she's been appearing
in always a bridesmaid
at the new theater is actress
Morgan Fairchild,
who you just saw played Matthew Perry's
TV mom and friends.
Thanks so much for joining us.
There's an unlimited number of clips
that you want to show
and you want to laugh at
and you want to be a part of.
But I want to start with
how would you remember
you said you were heartbroken.
How do you remember working with Matthew?
You know,
I just always remember Matthew
as from the first day on the set and
the show was not a huge hit yet
when I started working on it
and he came bounding over to me
and I literally bounding like a big puppy
and said, Oh,
you won't remember me,
but I used to visit you
on the set of Flamingo Road
and Falcon Crest with my dad.
And I said, Oh, who is your dad?
He said, John Bennett Perry.
I said,
Oh my God, you're that little kid.
It's like, Oh, okay.
And so right from the first
there was just that ebullience, that joy,
that kind of a friendly
and wonderful,
acerbic, but
puppy dog kind of feel about Matthew.
He was such a warm and
wonderful and funny and
creative young man.
You know,
I was looking at some of the pictures
over the weekend of us
and realized, oh, my God,
this is almost 30 years ago. Yeah.
So we've all grown up together.
The audience has grown up with Matt
as their best friend,
the person
they wanted to be, the person
they wanted to meet, to know
and have as a friend.
And we all kind of grew up together
with me.
Me being his fake mom.
Was so interesting.
We for years
watching friends saw
what he showed the world, right?
How funny he was,
what a great actor he was.
But then later in life,
when he wrote his book
and he came out
to talk about his addiction
and his struggles,
we also saw his reality and his humanity
and everything
that he has dealt with that
so many people could relate to.
And I just was moved.
MORGAN When he said, you know,
I want to be
someone who people
can come up on the street
and ask for help and I can help them.
And he wanted his legacy
to be a lot about that
and not just acting
well.
And I think that
was one of the very,
very special things about Matthew.
I watched him go from a young man
and he was 23, 24
when we started working together
and obviously had some issues
during the time he was on Friends.
I never saw it on the set.
He was always very professional.
But then when you started hearing
about some of the things
he had gone through,
I think one of the bravest things
that he did in his career
and his life was to go public,
to write this book,
to reach out to other people,
to try to be of help, to other people.
And that was one of the most
endearing things about him,
is that, as they said in the intro,
not only was
he always the funniest guy in the room
and the quickest wit and the most happy
and up seemingly,
but also one of the kindest
and having having had friends and family
with addiction problems
in my life, people that I cared about.
I know
how hard that is for the addict
and also for the people who love them.
And I thought it was terribly
brave of him to want that
to be part of his legacy as a human being
is not only the joy that he brought
to people, the great acting,
the great fun parts,
but also the reaching out
to trying to help
other people,
the being honest about what
he was facing in life.
Because to me,
that's what we're all really here
for, is to help each other
get through this.
And he was doing that big time.
That's really beautifully said.
It would mean a lot to him.
MORGAN, I'm sure.
Can I ask
before we let you go,
what made him so good at his job?
You mentioned that you never saw
any issues on set.
He was always
the funniest guy in the room.
His delivery.
I don't think you could mimic it
if you tried to study it for years.
What made him so great?
Okay. Okay. Go to work.
Well, you
know, I mean, I've gotten to work
with a few wonderful comics.
You know, Robin
Williams being one of them.
And he had that magnificent quality of
just being so quick,
so smart, so quick and that quick turn
and he could he could just pop up
with something
that you were not
expecting out of the blue.
And it made it work,
especially when we're working together
with this sort of weird
mother son
relationship that Chandler
and Nora
being had where he was always
so embarrassed
by her
and part of his neuroses,
trying to deal with his parents,
which I think a lot of kids could
identify with.
But he was just always so quick,
Just so quick
and in real life, too.
Very funny, very witty.
And it affected it affected his acting.
His acting showed that that quick turn
that cut you off guard, that
that made you laugh because he was
he was just a very endearing, fun,
wonderful, wonderful guy.
And I send my love
and condolences to his family.
I just felt that I should do something
because for millions of people
who watch the show, they
they sometimes think of me
as his mom, as Chandler's mom,
and I just I just
I just wanted to reach out
because I've gotten lots of condolences
on social media from all over the world.
You realize how many
how many people
this show touched,
how many people felt that
it helped them grow up,
that they identified with this character,
wanting to be the character,
be the best friend,
and just as his fake mom,
I just want to say how much I loved him
and how special he was
and and thank you to
let his
family know all the condolences
I have gotten to pass on to them.
So glad you joined
us, Morgan, this morning
for all those great memories.
Thanks very much.
Thank you. Thank you.